an addiction recovery non-profit is  actually now bringing back its president  who left after some pretty serious  sexual abuse allegations vegas stronger  says they did an internal investigation  into dave marlin and have cleared him of  any wrongdoing a former employee filed a  lawsuit against marlin accusing him of  sexually assaulting and harassing her  repeatedly this is a story the eye team  covered last year now court records are  showing that a settlement apparently was  reached and this lawsuit happened just  last week but it doesn't say the amount  vegas stronger also says that marlin was  cleared criminally as well we have asked  metro police about a criminal  investigation and are still awaiting a  response